o primeiro é questão que eu tenho para
ti é por quê que foi preciso juntar 24
veículos de comunicação para comprovar
se uma notícia é fake ou não fique 24
veículos eles foram reunidos em 2018
para as eleições presidenciais e foi uma
segunda fase de uma ideia que eu acho
que uma organização americana e inglesa
que querida quanta informação é bom
depois de um uma experiência prévia nas
eleições francesas a ideia não é só
fazer verificação de conteúdo suspeitos
encontrados nas redes sociais mas também
promover a colaboração entre os veículos
de comunicação é essa essa engenharia é
interessante porque
é realmente experimentar um trabalho de
colaboração trabalho que é muito
horizontal e até um pouco de um tudo que
a gente vê normalmente nas redações que
estão mais verticalizada é ela permite
que comprovam faça um determinado tipo
de trabalho e é quase impossível tanto
para veículos de comunicação sozinhos
quanto para agências de secagem trabalho
somente comes to present this guide como
nesse aspecto dele a gente consegue ter
fôlego e ter condição de fazer algumas
investigações de conteúdos suspeitos que
transitam nas redes sociais e
o que são mais complexos que exigem mais
mais gente envolvida mais recursos mais
capacidade de atender a fonte e
principalmente de uma coisa que a gente
civil pública tentar chegar na fonte
original da pessoa que criou o conteúdo
parece uma coisa muito simples na
verdade é uma coisa bastante complexa é
muito difícil a gente consiga pegar a
quem cria um determinado conteúdo não é
preciso de muitas ferramentas mas também
muito trabalho de verificação seguindo
os caminhos esse conteúdo foi tendo e às
vezes ele surgir plataformas diferentes
e importadas para algumas então é um
trabalho que que as a gente não secar já
tem dificuldade de fazer porque não
tenho tempo os seus e comprava consegue
e aí algumas vezes não não todas porque
tem essa capacidade de verificação pode
trabalhar com três quatro jornalistas em
uma única verificação uma verificação
que às vezes demora uma semana ou até
mais e ainda consegue que três ou quatro
outros veículos até mais difícil
envolvam em fazer o marco luque a gente
chama de crosspack em que é uma uma
verificação da verificação da coração
que foi feita né então é quase como se
que refizesse todo o trabalho fizesse
uma revisão da classificação que foi
feita encontra muita coisa vê se traz
uma nova ideia é um trabalho realmente
colaborativo e tem muito ganho isso é
assim e como é que vocês escolhem o que
vocês vão chegar e voltando um pouquinho
por quê que é importante buscar a fonte
daquela
a informação ou também já aproveitando
que uma desinformação né como é que é
esse conceito dentro é importante porque
a gente faz uma entrevista primeiro me
faz entrevista ao conteúdo a gente tem
hoje ele foi aí criados em uma foto onde
ela foi tirada quando ela foi tirada é
porque é em que condições qual foi o
contexto em que aquela foto foi
capturada com a imagem eu for cozido a
mesma coisa é muito importante porque às
vezes a gente tem uma visão e acha que a
fonte é alguém com grande capital social
e conseguiam fazer com que um
determinado conteúdo viralizar é muitas
vezes está vários degraus atrás dessa
pessoa a criação do conteúdo esse
conteúdo ele é criado num determinado
contexto
e vão sendo agregados o conteúdo várias
informações muitas vezes opiniões às
vezes interpretado e quando ele chega na
gente é muitas vezes está muito
modificado antes então nós temos
conteúdos por exemplo que foram gravados
problema está passando num determinado
local fez uma publicação é nós rede foi
simplesmente capturado por alguém que te
dá uma interpretação para aquilo e daqui
a pouco ele chega em alguém com capital
social bastante grande visualiza a
partir daí a gente não tem um sinal é
tão aliás até o começo desse processo a
gente costuma comprar a a informação de
quem fez visualizar né então nesse
sentido é
e portanto se isso chegar a quem pior né
eu não entendi definir o escopo tá os
corpo de verificação qual é o tema o que
que a gente vai fazer a gente começou em
2018 especiais do ano passado a gente
fez verifica pit públicas no governo
federal e agora a gente voltou um pouco
antes até do que nós gostaríamos de
voltar nos preparando para voltar para
cobrir as eleições municipais e um pouco
dos fenômenos que vão transitar no
entorno dessas dessas eleições e a gente
acabou voltando antes para atender
coronavírus então estamos agora
dedicados exclusivamente a corona vir
então como a gente decide a gente cria
primeiro faz uma avaliação do cenário
vários cenários para tríptico sagrada da
saúde para o tecnológico econômico e tal
e tenta extrair dessa avaliação do
cenário mas
e as palavras-chaves quais são as
hashtags que vão que vão dominar o
debate público sociais então as figuras
que que atacam que figura que são algo
nas redes sociais né e a partir disso a
gente constrói algumas planilhas se
alimentam software e softwares eles nos
ajudam a fazer monitoramento e se fica
pelos quais todos estão mais viralizando
são aqueles que conseguem alcance maior
engajamento maior esse é que o foco do
nosso trabalho então é a gente pesa um
pouco assim a nossa capacidade
o vídeo fiscal curou certa aqui que as
plataformas nos dão de conteúdo duvidoso
conteúdo suspeito a gente tem só fica
que consegue medir potencial de
visualização que der olhando um pouco
para o futuro não só pra que foi
consolidado até um determinado momento
ela usou algoritmos que medem um pouco a
as chances um capital social dos atores
envolvidos na
e com aquele conteúdo até aquele momento
e projeto e vai determinar o potencial
de visualização então gente olha sempre
potencial de realização porque a ideia é
que a gente nunca sabe que nós estamos
chegando nas pessoas que tiraram acesso
ao conteúdo do falso quando eu suspeito
e tu tem algum exemplo para dar que o
que vocês fizeram agora
é algo faço aqui vocês comprovaram que
era realmente uma fake news em relação
ao corona tem vários a gente publicou já
mais de 20 nesse nesses últimos dias e
mas dá-se uma ideia de engajamento a
gente não olha para coisas em menos de
sei lá 1500 compartilhamentos né porque
isso isso se potencializa o conteúdo mil
compartilhamentos por exemplos ele pode
chegar a 30 40 50 mil interações e pode
gerar isso até mais às vezes né então a
gente a gente pede sempre quais seu
estômago aquele tema que são suspeita né
que são duvidosa é a suspensão pode se
dar também sobre conteúdos que são
satíricos na medida em que os
comentários nos dão pistas
eu não tô entendendo como os conteúdos
práticos é o caso da famosa mamadeira de
[ __ ] né que a gente viu primeiro como
conta um site que foi olhando para ir de
aplicação para as pessoas estavam dando
para aqui no a gente considerou que eram
era um conteúdo de merecia ter uma
verificação hoje a gente por exemplo
investigou uma publicou agora há pouco
uma boato que explodiu de teríamos uma
bolsonaro wiki nessa semana que começa
liberado as pessoas com descontos que
todo mundo fosse para rua que o serviço
aí eu funcionando e isso tem ali de 250
mil visualizações um vídeo dela com esse
tipo de conteúdo né ele alisa bastante
importante citar aqui os conteúdos eles
pega tudo
é pública então o assunto do momento de
cloroquina então há uma busca por fora
minas mostrar no nessas ferramentas de
que a gente usa para medir a alcance
engajamento vamos trazer quase todo o
trabalho feito e a gente pode escolher o
que estava mais visualizando foi um
pouco do olhar jornalístico assim de ter
o quê que isso se tem algum tipo de
dúvida tem a eva para fazer o trabalho
de verificação existe algum perfil de
quem faz e de quem espalha não precise
direita são mais facilmente
identificáveis porque ele é bem
determinadas características assim na
forma de se apresentar o tipo de imagem
que eles utilizam então gente vê muito
bandeira do brasil muito bandeira de
israel grupos religiosos que utiliza
alguma previsão indo
e a cores são sempre verde amarelo então
é é muito os nomes não estão ligados nas
páginas da bolsonaro ou seja um muro o a
direita então eu termos que eles
utilizam muito a direita é mais
organizada nesse aspecto assim também aí
é mais fácil de identificar os
movimentos mais progressistas esquerda é
já não são tão articulados e-commerce
redes sociais então o nosso espectro de
portugal comparação
a gente está com o like e busca salvas
com aquelas páginas e perfis que a gente
já acompanha diretamente e as e as e as
músicas são as músicas que a gente salva
por por termos por palavras por exemplo
é na direita a gente encontra muito com
isso vendas diz na esquerda se para se
encontrar preciso fazer busca né porque
as coisas vende personagens de atores
diferentes né aquilo que mais viraliza
e a pose todos em muitos conteúdo e o
continente pelo conteúdo a segunda lente
interpretações que se dá alguns fatos e
algumas evidências muitas vezes são
enviesadas né então é muito muito do que
a gente encontra não é necessariamente
algum fabricado algo criado para enganar
diretamente todo o conteúdo eu não
entendi o uso de algum conteúdo
verdadeiro se atribui a ele vai ter uma
interpretação absolutamente facciosa e
se tenta vender estou na verdade
tá bom mas e aí falando da nossa
responsabilidade também né quando a
gente acaba espalhando algumas notícias
que são desinformação e o que são fake
também aonde tu tu acha que a gente tá
falhando a gente tá fazendo enxergar a
gente tá falhando em procurar fontes
confiáveis aonde estamos falhando para
que essas essa desinformação se espalhe
na velocidade da luz aí é que na
velocidade da luz viram redes sociais e
as cristãs passaram a ter uma uma ação
nesse mês ecossistema era uma ação e
anteriormente era reservada aos
jornalistas as pessoas que estavam
preparadas profissionalmente
e começa tudo do frozen ligar normal é
fazia um trabalho e de uma determinada
metodologia né e continuo fazendo só que
a gente tem uma um exército ovários
desertos de pessoas que hoje estão nas
redes sociais e cumprir então esse papel
de transmitir informação ao transmitir
conteúdos é o nós somos informação tudo
acho que disputam o espaço da atenção
das pessoas é
é e essas pessoas não foram preparadas
para nenhuma foram preparados para
produzir conteúdo o seguindo
determinados ritos da profissão de
jornalista como mesmo nossos analistas
nós estamos preparados às vezes para
alguma malícia que estão colocadas
nesses conteúdos né muitos analistas
compartilham conteúdo falso às vezes é
então assim eu acho que a coisa da fonte
é a busca na fonte sempre é a melhor
receita para quem quer se precaver um
pouco da dp vítima dando informação
porque a mesma ideia de fonte confiável
ela é uma ideia quieto prata para muita
gente né o que é o que é concreta mas em
fontes que absolutamente não são
confiáveis né a gente tem vários tipos
e foram criados the mixture of society
que utilizam a narrativa jornalística
passam simplesmente passar adiante e
compartilhar conteúdo são quantos com
conteúdos o filhote nível de
interpretativos e tal e falsos muitas
vezes se fazendo passar por conteúdos
jornalísticos né então no do debate
colocou com as pessoas normalmente a
gente vê muito isso assim as pessoas por
um determinado site com caio e que nós
sabemos que produzem de informação é e
internet locomoção de ser absolutamente
confiável né eu acho que eu acho que a
gente tinha um papel é zona rico que
trabalham com verificação tem um papel
muito próximo da quarentena mas a gente
já tá forma tá fazendo a contenção e um
determinado o volume de informação é
esperando que torna uma solução né
a função ela parte é muito de educação
midiática que as pessoas possam ter de
uma maior confiança então é
o mamão o papel mais preponderante do da
imprensa na imprensa e talvez seja mais
participativa mais transparente é que se
faça valer e agora a gente tem uma
oportunidade muito importante para isso
que é é o momento em que a gente tá na
imprensa dando voz a ciência né levando
informação de qualidade eu achei isso é